example good afternoon everyone good
afternoon distinguished guests
my name is tandy morrisonville i am the
manager of the louisiana cultural center
and the caribbean marketplace i have the
distinct honor of welcoming you to the
beautiful city of miami
specifically the vibrant neighborhood of
italy
on behalf of the city of miami and
sheridan cannon hardiman
the lightning cultural complex has
become the key engine
in downtown louisiana and nearby
neighborhoods
to support economic and community growth
over 100 000 people
visit here each year and take part
in our programs the complex is committed
to fostering imagination
creativity positive experiences for
children and adults year-round
our mission is to preserve
afro-caribbean culture
train the next generation of leaders and
leverage arts and culture
as tools of transformation and community
building
our vision is to be a cultural hub where
the community can meet
to create dialogue collaborate and build
an equitable reality for all americans
and their descendants
we are humbled to have with us today
former vice president joe biden and his
wife dr
jill biden
we are thrilled that the haitian
community is a priority for his team
as they campaign throughout south
florida
mr vice president dr biden
i have the honor of introducing you to
our distinguished
haitian-american elected officials
state representative dottie joseph
miami-dade county commissioner jean
monestime
north miami mayor philip bienema
north miami vice mayor dr alex dezume
north miami councilwoman marie esteem
irvin
[Applause]
north miami beach commissioner michael
joseph
north miami beach commissioner mackenzie
flermont
north miami beach commissioner paul
villard
north miami clerk vanessa joseph
we also salute our congresswoman miss
frederico wilson
i would like to present you and your
wife
with the beautiful memento from our
complex an extraordinary coffee table
book
by world renowned artist and author
haitian artist eduardo valkarie so it's
the book behind you
without further ado our
vice president mr joe biden well thank
you all
so very much sandy you've done a great
job here
thank you i uh uh
we found that uh crain john pierre who
was uh
works with me now was uh
and his haitian still hadn't forgiven me
when i was here in 2010
she had to go up to massachusetts with
the president she didn't get
to come down so we're finally making it
real thank you
i appreciate it sandy thank you and
congresswoman wilson you have been an
incredible
incredible force up in the congress for
all your constituents i really mean it
people listen to you you have great
moral sway
and i want to thank you for all you've
done and for your help in my campaign
and our campaign
and you all know that i am uh jill
biden's husband and
i want you to say hello to jill
and it's it's good to be back you know
in 2010
when the earthquake hit i came down here
uh for several reasons president i put
in motion
with the help of a lot of other people a
major effort to try to
rescue haitians in haiti in haiti from
that earthquake
i don't know whether some of you had
family there you lost family or they
were hurt but
i uh if it was that my heart goes out to
you because it was a sad
sad sad time but the most important
thing
that we wanted to make clear was that we
were going to make sure
temporary protective status was
guaranteed
to all haitians
and this is not the time
to lift it this is not the time to
end it look we have the same cultural
backgrounds
the same people of faith we believe in
the same things
we honor family family first
and after that and what
we do to help all people you know
i'm a practicing catholic there's an
expression by a famous
theologian who said faith sees
best in the dark what we need is faith
we need to never have faith in the
ability of people to overcome
great great crises and you have
the community has and you've reached out
you've left nobody behind you made sure
that people know they have a home with
you
there's nothing nothing more difficult
to deal with
we know from experience of loss of
family
if in fact you have nobody to lean on
nobody to help
nobody that understands and so thank you
and thank this center and all of you for
what you've done
to take care of so many incredible
people
folks the fact is that you know uh
it's all about the spirit the spirit of
this community
you know there's an expression i often
use i say there's no
quit in america there's no quit in
america
there's clearly no quit in the haitian
community
there is none and i promise you there'll
be no quit on my part
as your president making sure the
haitian community
has an even shot that's back on its feet
and moves in the direction that mabel
will realize it's
incredible incredible potential but
there's a lot happening
this is the most important election i
suspect that we'd agree in most of our
lifetimes
the character of the country is
literally on the ballot
what kind of nation we're going to be
who we are
what we stand for whether we'll continue
to reach out
or whether we'll continue to push people
away like it's happening now
whether we'll take care of those people
who are through no fault of their own
find themselves among those families
over 205
000 people have died from coven without
much help at all we can do so much
together and we can set an example
because this community is tight folks
millions of lives and livelihoods are on
the line
this is the last day you can register to
vote
in florida it matters
it genuinely matters because folks
the haitian community by itself
if the turnout was like it was last time
the haitian community itself
can determine the outcome of this
election i really mean
it look at the numbers it's real
so not only do you have an opportunity i
think you have an obligation
to see to it you take care of the folks
you care so much about
because i promise you i give you my word
as a bite and i'll be there
i'll stand with you there's so much we
can do
think about this the haitian community
here
little haiti grows and prospers
the whole of miami-dade prospers
nobody loses everybody wins
it's all about addition not like the
administration talks about subtraction
it's all about
addition as i said the fact
is that 29 days to go to this election
29 days and i
respectfully suggest if you haven't
already done it
encourage your friends your family your
constituents
to go to iwillvote.com
figure out exactly where you're going to
vote
exactly how you're going to vote and one
more thing
do what my grandfather used to say but
scranton find
the five people you're going to bring
along to vote not just you
reach out because a lot of people are
discouraged
and by the way everything the
administration has done has tried to put
a lid on people voting
everything making it sound like we can't
determine our own outcomes
we can the american people are showing
up
they're voting in large numbers it's
already begun
as you all know and quite frankly
if we win florida you've won you
flattened
so folks look the american people
floridians
folks in miami-dade they're looking to
you
you can deliver an awful lot you really
can
but here's a commitment jill and i make
to you and i mean it
if elected we'll be back not the last
you hear of me
i've never broken my word in anything
i've said the congresswoman can tell you
that
because look when the community grows
you set an example for other communities
other communities that are in trouble
that aren't getting an even
shot all we can do
to make sure that you don't go have the
problem you had with
your non-profit going under because of
the fact that you didn't get the kind of
help that was needed
it's there the congresswoman voted for
all that assistance it's there
but it's going to the big hitters it's
not going to ordinary hard-working
people
i i'm getting too wrapped up in this i
apologize but i feel really strongly
about this
and i think
think about this wouldn't it be an irony
the irony of all ironies if on election
eve it turned out
haitians delivered the coup de gras
in this election so ladies and gentlemen
the good news is for me i'm here the bad
news for you is
i'm coming back i'm coming back
and i want to see these beautiful young
ladies i want to see them dancing when
they're four years older too
oh it's great to see you so thank you
thank you
thank you thank you keep the faith
every time i walk out of my grandpop's
house the travel impressed me heard me
say this 100 times
but he'd say to me fabric he'd say joey
keep the faith
and my grandmother when she was alive
she said no joey spread it
go spread the faith god love you all
may god protect our troops thank you
thank you thank you thank
taking pictures you
oh where do you want me
[Music]
you